[Music]
okay hello everyone I am Nicolo and I
will talk to you about records and
tuples which is a proposal for a new
JavaScript syntax
I'm kind of sorry it's lunchtime I'm
with hangout now and those are not food
however if you stay here with me I have
stickers of the end of fragment apples
so don't come and ask me I have a lot of
them
so I worked on this uh at Galia in
partnership with Bloomberg
before
seeing what are aggress and doubles
let's first see what we are trying to
solve with this new JavaScript feature
uh so what is our problem
uh one programming there are two main
partings to main way to manage your
state your data you can have multiple
objects or immutable State and those are
usually used in object oriented
programming and in functional
programming however in many languages
such as JavaScript you can use both you
don't really have to choose you can mix
them
and in JavaScript while the mutable part
is really good like we have classes we
have a lot of different things we don't
really have good Primitives for
immutable state
there are some very good JavaScript
libraries that gives us this capability
they are just not
included in the language itself
for example the most popular one is
immutable JS how many of you have ever
used the multiple Js
well quite a bit nice I've
I must never use the Moto GS just like
once or two times uh however uh just for
those who don't know what it is it's a
library that provides some structures
parallel to the built-in JavaScript
objects but it working in an immutable
way for example we have Maps which are
kind of like objects
and you can
update those immutable data structures
without modifying the original one but
creating a copy so for example we can
create a new map where B is 4 instead of
two the original map is not modified and
then immutable GS provides some
utilities to compare
to immutable data starters for example
we can check if two maps are equal a
according to multiple JS and it has some
utilities to convert code back to plain
JavaScript
another popular library is inner uh
email uses plain JavaScript objects so
you don't have to learn this parallel
like immutable data structures and it
provides some utilities to update them
in a way that looks mutable but doesn't
really change the original object so the
original object remain remains unchanged
and we get a new object with updated
property and this is again a really good
Library the only problem is that uh well
it has some problems that I'm going to
show uh the main one is that it's a
library so you have to to include in
your code and it does not just work
and so
as I was saying every library has its
own problems and this is not because of
the library it's because JavaScript does
not give them the tools necessary to
build something that works perfectly
so the one big problems that you have to
learn are completely different things uh
you have to learn like this new
equivalent of objects and arrays you
have to learn how to get properties from
them how to update them and so for
example you cannot write code that bot
works that works both with plain
JavaScript objects and with immutable JS
you have to choose
and another big problem is that equality
is not agreed upon across everything
because JavaScript has its own
definition of equality while for example
limitable.js has its own different
definition of equality so for example if
you create a JavaScript set containing
an immutable list that only contains
zero one according to JavaScript it the
set does not contain this other list
which looks the same however according
to the mutable set
to the set in the immutable just words
the equality here works and so we like
checking if this list is contained
returns true
and this is a problem uh
because every Library used you have to
check if it works or not with the
immutable library that you're using uh
as an exam as a practical example
assuming that you have a react component
and you are using immutable Js
uh this is a component that at some
point gets rendered in the game and
let's assume that map renderer is a
component that well renders the map the
immutable map that we have and that for
some reason this is a very expensive
operation so we want to skip the
rendering the nested component if
possible
however and we're always passing the
same map or at least a map with the same
contents to these component So in theory
react could skip rendering it
however
the map is always the same according to
multiple.js like if we use the equality
function of multiple JS it would have
done true for all those Maps however
according to JavaScript there are all
different Maps because they're all
different objects and so react
re-renders the map renderer component
every time
okay so with the records and Apple's
proposal we are trying to solve these
problems
records and tuples are a new type of
JavaScript value they are similar to
object and arrays they're just immutable
they even have the same syntax except
that it's prefix within hash
and records and tuples are compared by
their contents rather than by reference
or by pointer which is how objects are
compared like if you have two objects
with the same content they can still be
the same object this is not true for
excellent apples two records or tuples
with the same contents are really the
same
records and doubles are Primitives so
they have the wrong type of so you can
easily check if something is a record
rather than a classic object and they
can only contain other Primitives why
there are Primitives uh because
Primitives are already compared checking
their contents for example two strings
are equal if they contains the same
Charters even if you didn't create them
in the same place
and it's easy to Define what deeper
quality means on Primitives because you
can just recursively check
their contents for objects this is more
difficult because as we saw for example
with immortal.js there can be different
opinions regarding the quality of
objects and also only using Primitives
gives us deep immutability guarantees so
giving us some stronger security
warranties without having to remember
for example to freeze every object every
time
and a bit more in detail how are records
and taples compared well first
recursively so uh two records are equal
if every property of the record is equal
and if you find other records and
doubles you check their contents again
tuples are ordered because they're like
a Race So two tuples are the same not
only if they contain the same values but
also if they're the same order and
records are not so uh for records you
only check that for every given property
name you have the same value regardless
of the definition order
in records and tuples and amps values
and
are equal and positive negative zero are
equal and this is kind of an edge case
but it's something very important to
preserve because it makes it possible to
not worry about Sears and nuns instead
of deep records and double structures
and you can still see if two records of
two tuples containing positive zero
negative zero are different using
object.ies which is how we already check
if you have a positive or negative zero
like outside of record Apple
and finally since we defined what it
means to be equal for regular Tuple
directly in the language it works
everywhere so for example it works in
mapping sets you can have a map where
the key is a tuple or a record so you
can have like
a compound key multiple values in the
same key
and also like every Library
uh every JavaScript library that exists
would already know how equality for
records and doubles works because it's
just the normal JavaScript quality so if
we look again at our react example but
using a record rather than an immutable
JS map this time
react does not render the map renderer
component every time because the data is
the same like for real or actually
according to react because it's the same
according to JavaScript and not to some
specific library that we chose
okay so records and doubles are
immutable uh but
apps are Dynamic so we need to like
update our state how do we update
records and doubles we do it in the same
way as we update
it's not really update as we create new
objects with different contents without
modifying the original objects so we can
just use spread for example to replace
some properties records
and for tuples we can use all the array
methods that do not mutate the array
such as filter or map or
reduce all the methods that return a new
value without modifying the original
value
and what about the other array methods
so for example a Reddit push or return
shift well for those it's easy you don't
really need those methods you can just
use spread so there are no alternative
for those methods that modified original
right you just create a new Tuple so
spreading the contents of the original
one and adding one element at the end or
at the beginning and the same is for
popular shift you can you can just use
lies
then we have a Reddit field and a Reddit
copy Within those methods are really
specialized for mutating stuff and it
does not make sense to have an immutable
version of that
uh because they are used for some like
performance critical things where you
need to do as few operations as possible
and this is just not just not possible
with tuples so they're not supported
and what about the other four arrayments
well that are three RM methods and then
the like setting an array elements like
it makes sense to sort a double to get
the sorted version of a tapple the
problem is that this sort array method
modifies the original array and so this
doesn't work on immutable things
so let's put aside for a moment to
record some doubles proposal and let's
take a quick look at the change array by
copy proposal which is born as a like
child proposal of the record Center plus
one
have you ever read them like array.flies
that Traverse or latest source I have
many times because many times I want to
like reverse an array without modifying
the original version and having to use
two methods is not really clear like if
I'm reading this code why do I need to
First Slice it without any arguments to
then reverse it or to then sort it so
the change area by copy proposal
introduces alternatives to these methods
that mutate the array when it's not
really necessary for example instead of
a red dot sort we now also have a Reddit
to sorted which returns a new array
which is just well assorted and the same
for the Traverse we have to reverse and
instead of splice we have to splice
and lastly for setting a specific
element in the array or well for
creating a new array where a specific
element has been replaced we could use
two splice interior but let's
like that's probably the most
hard to use every methods so we are also
introducing this already twist that lets
you specify
a specific entry of the array
and all these methods have been to the
story to type the array so that they are
all consistent and you can also use them
on tuples so that you can just memorize
this shared API that works across all
the array like built-ins and you don't
have to learn different things depending
on whether you want multiple things or
immutable things
okay back to records and doubles uh
We've now seen that records and tuples
uh like are compared recursively that
their Primitives contain Primitives
we've seen which methods we can use on
them
uh there is one more problem
there are Primitives technology content
other Primitives but JavaScript is full
of objects like the Dom is objects every
function is an object we have map sets
depth arrays promises
almost everything is an opportunity in
JavaScript and we cannot just say okay
you chose to use record apples you
cannot use objects anymore that's not
realistic
so how do you reference objects inside
of records and tuples
well we have explored different
alternatives
and none of them was really good
preserving this security and the
immutability guarantees the records and
doubles give because
if the goal like referencing multiple
objects and having full immutability are
conflicting goals and there isn't a good
way to make them work together
so the solution is records and tuples
still cannot contain objects but you can
reference objects using like symbol
placeholders so you can put a symbol in
the record and have a side table saying
okay this symbol corresponds to this
object and then a side table the other
way around saying this object
corresponds to the symbol so that you
have this one-to-one mapping and you can
translate every object to corresponding
primitive
so if I want to get the on click
function for this record I get this
corresponding symbol and then I check
okay what is the function corresponding
to the symbol and this might seem really
complex but in practice all that part
can be easily abstracted by Library
there is no library in npm yet to do so
just because records and tuples only
proposal it's not like implemented yet
in most engines
but there is a problem with this
approach which is cabbage collection so
garbage collection is a mechanism that
the the browser has to avoid using a lot
of memory so if you create many objects
as soon as those objects are not
reachable anymore from your code which
means that they're not like stored in a
variable or stored in a property of
another object the the JavaScript engine
can delete them from memory those frame
some memory
the problem with using Maps is that if
you put objects in maps they cannot be
garbage collected anymore because you
could always like as long as you have
access to the map you could like iterate
over its elements and get all its keys
so these objects would last forever and
your application would start leaking a
lot of memory and at some point it might
crash
and this solution to this is to use weak
Maps rather than Maps the only problem
is that weak Maps cannot contain symbols
so a third proposal which again was born
for records and tuples is the symbols as
with maki's proposal
uh so what does it do well the name
might be self-explicative but uh so we
can divide JavaScript values into
categories we have values that can be
garbage collected and values that cannot
I'm calling them forgeable values and I
explain why in a moment so well I'll
explain it now let's first look at the
first ball values column first of all
values are values that you can recreate
so if you have a string that contains
some contents and then you later like
stop referencing the string
in theory the engine could garbage
collect it but then you can create the
same string again uh like even outside
of your program you could fetch it from
a server or like create it from the
number code points so you could create
this same string again and you could
observe using Maps or weak maps that the
original value has been deleted
on the other hand garbage collectible
values are values that you cannot
recreate anymore so if you have an
object and you lose access to this
object there is no way you can create an
object which is the same one because for
two object to be the same one it means
that
not that they haven't seen contents but
that it was really like created in that
single place
and so we have unique symbols that well
are unique by definition so they're also
garbage collectible and we have on the
other side registered symbols which are
symbols that are not unique and you can
recreate the same symbol every time by
giving to the simulator function the
same description it's kind of like
symbol.iterator or symbol dot uh
symbol of iterator that you can reuse
many times
and lastly with this proposal we will
also have records and tuples which are
kind of both sides and this is kind of
strange but if you think about it a
record that contains a symbol that you
cannot recreate uh can be garbage
collected because if you do not have the
symbol anymore you cannot recreate the
same record anymore well a record that
contains for example only strings is
forgeable because you can just take the
same string like recreate the same
strings put them together to create the
record
moment only objects are allowed as weak
map keys
[Music]
um
as you might imagine
this proposal extends the valid with my
keys to also unique symbols so that uh
we can now use weak map keys to have
weak maps to actually have this symbol
to object mapping to put things in
records and doubles
so this was a very
lightweight overview I did um about
there is one big question like I've
shown you like records and tuples change
rebeccupy methods symbols with my keys
but is this something that you can
actually use like can you go home and
start using them tomorrow
or on Monday tomorrow and Sunday don't
use them
well yes and no so those are only
proposals they will hopefully be added
to a JavaScript version in the future uh
there are at a good stage in the
standardization process so they it's at
this point certain that it will be added
it will take time
however you can start
using some of them for the change drive
by copy there are already many poly
Fields such as es shims and core JS
code yes is quite popular maybe some of
you already use that
and also it has been released in Safari
16 last week so I just updated these
slides yesterday night because I I saw a
tweet about this Safari release notes
and change over copy was there so you
can already start using this proposal in
a browser right now
seamless with my keys is unfortunately
not polyfillable because it's adding a
real new capability to the language like
something that
cannot be done in any other way and it
has not been released yet in any browser
so
we can only lick memory for now when
they uh hopefully next year uh browsers
we're still implementing seamless with
Marquis and we can actually have these
mappings in a memory Safe Way
and finally records and doubles
well records and taples is new syntax so
you cannot really just polyfill that
however there is a Babel plugin
uh does any one of you use the Bible
nice okay there is a Babel plugin uh for
those who know Babel I'll let you
compile modern JavaScript syntax or
proposals to older syntax so that you
can use them even in other browsers or
in browsers that do not support the
syntax that you want to use
uh there is a Babel plugin that allows
you to compile a constant Apple so that
it works in every browser uh
and I don't suggest using that in
production because proposals can change
there are a lot of very cool JavaScript
proposals uh and it's very important
that people
test them so that we see if they work or
not like if it's a good idea or not but
please never use those in production yet
and also we have an online playground so
uh there is some like well an online
playground where you can actually type
your records and doubles code and see
how it works see how the quality Works
uh test I think it also supports the
change right by copy methods so you can
it's kind of like a browser console
except that it supports circles and
doubles uh you probably don't need to
copy the link like if you Google for
record couple playground it will be one
of the first few results
and that's all uh if you have any
questions I'm happy to answer them like
just look for me around
uh I'm the one with the pink hoodie uh
you can also contact me on Twitter for
any question related uh like either to
this proposals I'm working on or to
other JavaScript proposals uh or I'm
into anything that I do that you might
want to not want about or you can
contact me on Matrix which no one knows
but no one uses it but in my opinion is
the best chat protocol that exists
and
that's all thanks and let's all have
lunch now
[Applause]